>> MICHAEL MOORE IS NOW MAKING
DISASTER MOVIES, HIS NEW ONE AN
EIGHTH PLACE FLOP MAKING ONLY $3
MILLION TOTAL.
IT SANK FASTER THAN THE
POSEIDON.
DOES THE FLOP MATTER?
MEANWHILE, THE COASTAL ELITES
USE MORE -- AS A VIRTUE SIGNAL.
THE FRENCH SAY 2 SAME THING SO
THE LIE STANDS.
MOORE’S FILMS ARE LIKE VITAMIN
SUPPLEMENTS.
MOST OFFER ZERO BENEFIT BUT YOU
STILL SAY NICE THINGS ABOUT HIM
BUT TO HIS CREDIT, MOORE’S
MOVIES ARE OVERTLY POLITICAL.
UNLIKE THE REST OF HOLLYWOOD,
WHERE THEY INJECT POLITICS TO
GET STUFF MADE.
THEN THERE IS THAT PART ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AT LEAST MOORE WEARS HIS
POLITICS ON HIS SLEEVE.
GOD KNOWS THERE IS PLENTY OF
ROOM.
I’M SURE THE MEDIA EXPECTED THE
FILM TO OPEN BIG.
A REJECTION OF TRUMP AND YOU.
IT DIDN’T AND IT WASN’T.
THE LESSONS, IDEOLOGY AS
ENTERTAINMENT IS AS LOONY AS A
COLONOSCOPY FOR RECREATION.
PLUS AMERICA DOESN’T NEED A
LECTURE FROM A RICH DUDE ABOUT
HOW BAD THINGS ARE WHEN THINGS
ARE GOOD.
OUR COUNTRY’S METRICS LOOK GREAT
WHICH TURNS MOORE’S CINEMA INTO
A FAIRY TALE.
AS USUAL, WHEN THERE ARE FLOPS
THE MEDIA IGNORES IT.
IF IT WAS NUMBER ONE YOU CAN BET
HE WOULD BE EVERYWHERE.
THERE IS AN OLD SAYING, YOU
DON’T REPORT ON PLANES THAT
DON’T CRASH BUT YOU ALSO DON’T
REPORT ON YOUR FAVORITE BELIEFS
THAT DO.
YOU KNOW, JUDGE, WE JUST WANTED
TO ESCAPE.
WHO GOES TO MOVIES FOR
POLITICAL, WOULD YOU GO TO SEE A
POLITICAL MOVIE RIGHT OR LEFT?
>> JUDGE PERINO: I’M DYING TO GO
TO A MOVIE.
I’M TRYING TO GET ANYONE TO TAKE
ME TO THE MOVIES.
I WOULD GO TO MICHAEL MOORE?
>> YOU HAVE TO DO SOMETHING,
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DON’T THINK --
>> JUDGE PERINO: YOU AND I
COULDN’T AGREE ON A MOVIE.
>> I’LL PICK A MOVIE.
>> JUDGE PERINO: BEN HUR.
>> SOMETHING IN THIS CENTURY.
>> JUDGE PERINO: "GONE WITH THE
WIND"?
KENNEDY WHAT DO YOU WANT TO SEE?
>> WHAT DO I WANT TO SEE?
GOSH, I LOVE MARVEL MOVIES.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD YOU LOVE?
THE NEW NICHOLAS CAGE MOVIE.
MANDY.
IT’S FANTASTIC.
>> I HEARD HIS CHARACTER IS
UNREAL.
BUT IT’S SO FUNNY BECAUSE WE’RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS, WE’RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT MOORE BECAUSE IT’S
NOT ENTERTAINMENT, IT’S NOT HOW
PEOPLE CONSUME THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION.
EVERYONE HAS GIANT COSTCO TVs,
50-INCH PLATINUM TV OR PLASMA,
WHATEVER.
SOON FOX NATION, YOU’RE ABLE TO
WATCH THIS INCREDIBLE CONTENT
AND YOU GO TO MOVIES FOR TOTAL
ESCAPISM.
THAT’S WHEN YOU --
>> BECAUSE, IN FACT, MICHAEL
MOORE HAD SOME HIT MOVIES THAT
WERE ABOUT NEWS.
BUT NOW I THINK NEWS IS SO
OMNIPRESENT.
>> FAKE NEWS.
>> SO THE BIG WEEK -- THE BIG
MOVIE IN MY FAMILY THIS WEEKEND
WAS "THE HOUSE WITH A CLOCK IN
THE WALLS."
>> WAS THAT GOOD?
>> I DIDN’T GO, EVER WENT EXCEPT
ME BECAUSE I WORKED.
>> THEY LIKED IT?
>> THEY LOVED IT.
THE LITTLE GUYS GOT A LITTLE
SCARED BUT THAT’S WHERE PEOPLE
WENT.
THEY DIDN’T GO TO MICHAEL MOORE
BUT I THINK IT’S BECAUSE THE
NEWS IS KIND OF ROUGH.
>> YOU NEED ESCAPISM.
>> HERE’S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE FIRST AND SECOND.
THE FIRST MOVIE WAS BASED ON A
CONSPIRACY THEORY AND THE
AUDIENCE LOVES THAT REMEMBER THE
SAUDI CONNECTION TO THE BUSH
FAMILY.
DICK CHENEY’S WAR PROPHETEERS.
THE CRITICS LOVED IT BECAUSE IT
WAS FRESH.
THERE IS NO CONSPIRACY WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
IT’S ALL OUT IN THE OPEN.
THERE IS NOTHING GOING ON BEHIND
THE SCENES.
IF ANYTHING, PEOPLE ARE
CONSPIRING AGAINST HIM AND IF
YOU WANT ANTI-TRUMP PROPAGANDA,
YOU WATCH CNN OR YOU WATCH
MSNBC.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT’S INTERESTING,
AND MICHAEL MOORE WAS ONE OF THE
FEW PEOPLE WHO CALLED THE
ELECTION AHEAD OF TIME.
THERE WERE VERY FEW, SO MANY
PEOPLE, ALL THE POLLSTERS WERE
OFF AND HE WAS THE ONE PERSON ON
THE LEFT, I KNOW THESE PEOPLE, I
KNOW THESE PEOPLE IN MICHIGAN
AND THE RUSTBELT AND THEY ARE SO
DISENFRANCHISED, WHAT HE’S
SAYING RESONATES, AND HE COULD
EASILY WIN, AT LEAST THIS PART
OF THE COUNTRY AND HE WAS
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
SO HE MAKES A BETTER ANALYST.
>> THEY THOUGHT SOMEBODY ELSE
WAS BENEFITING, NOT THEM.
I THINK THAT’S WHAT IT IS.
AND JESSE, BY THE WAY, I JUST,
TO ME, WHEN YOU LOOK AT MICHAEL
MOORE, IT SEEMS TO ME MICHAEL
MOORE WAS HITTING SOMETHING THAT
WAS VERY REAL BEFORE, AND YOU